okay you ready I think often with the
more complicated log walls like saying a
chronic one the division one only the
trickiest one is the trickiest idea is
whenever starting okay so I think you
have to say for instance let X equal and
you wanted to find something like say
the log base a of B and these are the
two things are going to change okay does
that make sense so what okay I think
we're going to rewrite this as an index
equation often with all of the pressure
log laws you're going to try and bring
it back down to an index which you know
your index there so how do I write it
basically comes the base this subject
becomes your power all right now what
you what I introduced with your change
of base bore is a good number right so
I've got these two and I want to get
like log base 10 or log base E or some
other thing right so they call it C I
think it was communicative life so if I
take log base C of both sides this is
going to become a BX
that's that yes
but he I noticed something right this X
this exponent I can take out the front
all right you can see I'm always there
okay so I'm going to do two things on
this line okay number one I'm gonna
divide through and number two I know
what X is because I defined it so I'm
just gonna stop it back in okay so on
the left hand side here's my X and then
I'm gonna keep this guy or the other
side I'm going to divide through there's
your change of base so you see I needed
to have this um exponent here I need to
have that law established so either the
question will say you may have stood
that oh uh or it'll be like pop one
print this they totally cool absolutely
cuz on this do you think about it okay
um what are they testing their are
testing your beliefs actually nor how
log balls work and particularly how they
relate to index laws I think that's the
important part
gave you the fact that they're inverse
functions of each other now by the way
I'll just use this to on remind you of
something I don't know most people don't
get to this okay so it's a it's a not
very discussed that but but when you are
let B equal C so remember C is any
number you like okay so if I just
specify that this is you okay what
happens to this something interesting
but what you have up here and you have
log base B of B log base B of B which is
1 and then on the bottom you've got log
base B of A so you've got a reciprocal
here it's funny have you ever seen this
before so often this is kind of a useful
property sometimes you see a and then B
and you feel like it's a mess to try and
solve the equation you've got but you
can switch them very very easily
alright anyway